[Musique]
j'ai vécu ça un peu comme un tremblement
taille jackson
oui un monde qui finissaient tous les
employés qui étaient là maintenant sont
démunis
pour nous à ranger 2010 très suspect
très chichement les alarmes qui sommet
tous les indices suggèrent i ces
compagnies sont en ligne pour l'instant
même
[Musique]
le couperet est tombé en janvier les
derniers magasins s'ils ont fermé leurs
portes laissant des milliers d'employés
et de retraités en plein désarroi quant
à l'avenir de leur fonds de retraite
tu as travaillé pour ça honteux des fois
pas augmenter parce qu'on ne vienne pas
dans ton fonds de pension piquant
conteuse retire moi je trouve que c'est
une forme de bol pendant des années les
retraités de seals ont vu le déficit de
leur fonds de pension se creuser pendant
que les actionnaires de la compagnie
empoché des milliards la liquidité est
alors l'argent et la pare chocs a pris
la décision de s'adresser aux déficits
ils ont tout fait pour mettre leur
retraite à l'abri mais tout le monde les
a laissés tomber
jamais je n'aurais cru on en viendrait à
ça
qui aurait cru qu après 65 ans
d'activité le géant s'écroulerait avec
son fameux catalogue sears était
pourtant le amazon des années 70 et 80
une compagnie d'avant garde qui livrait
de tout partout
malgré sa voix un peu mécanique
l'ordinateur est toujours polis quoi
qu'on lui dise
[Musique]
à l'époque c'est juste canada est une
filiale de l'américaine serge gros bacs
voici l'édifice commercial le plus haut
du monde en plein coeur de chicago
la tour sears a longtemps symbolisé la
puissance de l'entreprise
c'est alan est pas qu on a la taille et
la première journée quarante ans plus
tard la rumeur a travaillé chez sears
pendant plus de 30 ans dont la moitié
comme vice président il a quitté en 2005
quand il a senti le vent tourner un
fonds d'investissement américain vient
de prendre le contrôle de sites aux
états unis et de sa filiale
sears canada à sa tête et d'hellemmes
porte une star de wall street 2 fois
milliardaire
le tout change dès son arrivée
si elle se prend un important virage la
première manoeuvre
non j'ai maintenant au canada était
d'abord de crédit avec la carte de
crédit était un lien crucial avec nos
clients
marc cohen était le patron de la rumeur
il a été pdg de sirius canada avant la
prise de contrôle par le fonds
spéculatif nos activités de crédit est
une source de revenus importante et très
profitable des poires la vente de la
carte de crédit rapporte 2,2 milliards
de dollars 6 verse 1 milliard et demi à
ses actionnaires du jamais vu
et au lieu de réinvestir cet argent dans
la compagnie comme frais la plupart des
entreprises
il l'a donnée aux actionnaires sous
forme de dividendes et il est le
principal actionnaire
ainsi il n'a pas pris part à cette
décision
elle relève du conseil d'administration
de sears canada sur lequel il n'a dit il
aucune autorité
mais l'ex pdg marc cohen est d'avis
qu'il exerçait une certaine influence
il enseigne aujourd'hui à l'université
columbia
c'est un expert en commerce de détail
est depuis longtemps un adversaire très
critique de la gestion de ce qu'ils
souhaitent ils emportent spiegel à tout
et ça a été le début d'un démantèlement
des actifs qui a nui à l'entreprise qui
a paralysé l'entreprise et qui a fini
par tuer une entreprise
d'un des plus grands commerces de détail
au pays
l'entreprise sera fragilisée
progressivement par des coupures sans
précédent les investissements pour
entretenir les magasins et développer
les activités de la compagnie chutent de
manière draconienne de conduire des
mailles agenda les dernières années
j'étais gêné de voir chez bel air j'ai
vu le déclin par les filles qui me
disait que ça change et qui avait pu la
même marchandise la chante marchandise
était différent la façon de la mise en
marché changer aussi les consommateurs
réagissent mal aux changements les
ventes se mettent à dégringoler
et c'était crève coeur d'exit man est un
spécialiste de la transformation
d'entreprises
il a été embauché comme vice-président
pour relancer la marque 6 en 2012 mais
il n'a pas senti le soutien des membres
du conseil d'administration pendant ces
années difficiles
c'était difficile d'avoir leur attention
il ne vais même pas les yeux de leur
écran d'ordinateur en santé aucun
intérêt pour nos projets
fin 2013 plutôt que d'investir pour
relancer la compagnie sise verse un
autre important dividende d'un demi
milliard de dollars à ses actionnaires
au grand étonnement de l'équipe de
direction
13 a été une année charnière avec le
recul qu'ils aient choisi ce moment pour
émettre de gros dividendes n'avait pas
de sens bah quand une entreprise veut
survivre
les retraités voient les actionnaires
s'enrichir alors que leur caisse de
retraite subi les contrecoups de
l'économie et s'appauvrit on n'a pas vu
un choc chez dividendes mais folle
passion j'ai conclu que la compagnie
n'avait pas l'intention de rencontrer
ses obligations envers les employés le
fonds de retraite affiche désormais un
déficit est considéré toujours que de
ces deux solstices une lumière rouge
si votre ampleur devait faire faillite
vous êtes dans le doubs michel disais
est économiste à la retraite ce que
j'aurais dû faire c'est profiter que ça
allait encore bien pour équilibrer un
peu ce qu'elle verse aux actionnaires et
ce qu'elle verse aux régimes de retraite
vous aurez l'argent
de 2005 à 2013 au total près de 4
milliards de dollars d'actifs sont
vendus et trois milliards et demi de
dollars sont redistribués aux
actionnaires
c'est dix fois plus que les dividendes
distribués dans la décennie précédente
tout ce qu'il faisait c'était récolté
l'argent dans une entreprise en 2014 des
exumas quitte la compagnie déçu
aujourd'hui tout ça m'apparaît comme une
hypocrisie
c'est horrible comment ça s'est terminé
les retraités craignent désormais le
pire que la compagnie fasse faillite et
que le déficit de la caisse de retraite
entraîne une réduction de leur
prestation pour le reste de leurs jours
il sonne l'alarmé auprès de la
commission des services financiers de
l'ontario clean gta déjà ce qu'on charme
au point de vue surveille annonce peer
intervention c'est d'aller me est clair
pour nous la compagnie étant
techniquement et ce en améliorant du
plan d'action
les retraités demandent à la commission
de forcer 6 à rembourser le déficit du
fonds de retraites et de confier sa
gestion un tiers pendant que cette
bataille se joue l'actionnaire principal
et des limpers recrute un collaborateur
et ancien employé brandon strazeele
il sera le dernier président de sears
canada parce qu'on aurait pu faire les
choses autrement
c'est une question très lourd de sens et
vous le savez le crachin
[Musique]
brandon strazeele va tenter l'impossible
sauver une compagnie moribonde il est le
dernier espoir des retraités hamilton en
ontario
une ville qui s'est bâtie sur la civ
comme son père et son grand père avant
lui ce que duval a passé le plus gros de
sa vie dans ses usines
c'était le pain et le beurre des gens
d'ici toutes les familles en dépendent
mais cette sécurité a été menacé
plusieurs fois scott duval et les vingt
mille autres retraités de stelco ont dû
se battre pour sauver leur fonds de
retraite déficitaire pour nous c'est du
vol
c'est notre argent personnes devraient
avoir le droit de s'en servait pour
combler le déficit shaul fort des
millions de canadiens qui mise sur un
fonds de retraite à prestations
déterminées sont à risque et scott duval
trouve que l'histoire se répète trop
souvent dans le cas de six
le déficit est apparemment devenu
insurmontable en 2015
c'est ce qu'affirme en tout cas son
nouveau président brandon 30 elle dit
avoir hérité d'une entreprise dont les
revenus ont chuté de moitié et qui perd
de l'argent
on n'aurait pas survécu
c'était devenu impossible de financer le
fonds de retraite et investir dans la
compagnie il aurait fallu faire dans le
passé
mais dans le passé au moment aussi où je
faisais encore des profits au lieu de
rembourser le déficit
elle a profité de mesures d'allégement
offerte par le gouvernement ontarien
ces mesures devaient aider les
compagnies à traverser la crise
économique
elles ont permis à 6,2 reporté des
paiements à sa caisse de retraite
nous avons toujours veillé à respecter
les règles
tout indique que sur reverser ce que la
loi est jugée province et taiwan mandat
passé le conseil d'administration doit
trancher entre des intérêts divergents
ceux des actionnaires et ceux des
retraités de la compagnie elo
certainement violé le contrat moral
entre les employés jusque là fait est
parfaitement légal c'est un peu comme
certaines formes d'évitement fiscal
c'est parfaitement légal et parfaitement
immoral d'alcool est une analyste
financière indépendante elle aussi
estiment que steve a failli à ses
devoirs et va plus loin et c'est son
conseil d'administration sont les
premiers responsables
lorsqu il gère le fonds pension ils ont
une responsabilité fiduciaire est une
obligation de diligence en vertu de la
loi canadienne
mais il n'ya pas que sears qui aurait pu
en faire plus pendant deux ans et demi
le comité des retraités a tenté sans
relâche de convaincre les autorités de
mettre son régime de retraite à l'abri
25 interventions au gouvernement notre
caillou au ministère des finances le 1er
mai 10 dont aliot hdnet combler les
lions pour aj diana record s'explique
mal l'inaction de la commission des
services financiers fait score la
commission a le même niveau de
responsabilité fiducial de chéri du riz
la commission avait le pouvoir d'agir
pour que le déficit du fonds de pension
soit comblé par cible
dans un courriel la commission a fourni
peu d'explications sur sa décision de ne
pas intervenir
elle s'est borné à rappeler que 6 s'est
conformé aux exigences minimales prévues
par la loi en juin 2010 est acculé au
pied du mur
6 se place sous la protection de la loi
dans l'espoir de se restructurer mais
quatre mois plus tard en octobre
elle doit se résigner à tous les kids et
du jour au lendemain seize mille
retraités apprennent qu'à moins d'une
solution miracle leurs prestations
seront amputés de presque 20% mais il
est m'énervant les gens s'imaginent
beaucoup mais ces quelques milliers de
dollars
alors j'aurai envie de vous le dire mais
je veux pas mettre personne dans
l'embarras c'est très minerve je peux
pour faire mon épicerie d'un année avec
100 le sort des retraités de 6 relance
vieux débat
[Musique]
de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent au
canada pour demander une meilleure
protection pour les travailleurs
retraités
lorsque leur ancien employeur fait
faillite le canada est permis les
derniers pays industrialisés à
considérer encore ces retraités comme de
simples créanciers après les banques les
avocats les comptables les investisseurs
même après les gouvernements alors de
pain que les banques et les
investisseurs valade bien traités mais
nous aussi et gouvernement doit agir
parce que les gens sont en train de tout
perdre
l'ex travailleur de stèles cause que
duval compte bien régler le problème
aujourd'hui député fédéral pour le parti
néo démocrates ils sillonnent le pays
pour promouvoir un projet de loi
crisique le bloc québécois a déposé un
projet semblable
les deux demandes qu'on rembourse
d'abord les retraités en cas de
restructuration ou de faillite coach de
maintenir sa place les rats traités en
priorité
non mais aucun autre créancier ne serait
remboursé tente le fonds de retraite ne
serait pas comblé
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
essaie de changer le statut des
retraités dans la loi fédérale mais sans
succès déplore l'ex pdg de sirius canada
highway la droite
j'aurais pensé qu'après l'effondrement
de nortel waps le gouvernement serait
devenu plus sensible nous faillite des
grandes compagnies au rôle scared
cette bataille pour changer la loi diana
katla menées en 2010 après la chute de
nortel le changement n'a jamais été
adopté en grande partie en raison de
l'opposition de ce qu'elle appelle
l'industrie de la faillite
thomas steffen opposition il ya eu une
opposition virulente de la part de
l'association canadienne des banquiers
de l'institut de les soldats d'élite
et du conseil des chefs d'entreprise
l'objection vous allez avoir des
décisions financières des employeurs de
toute l'industrie de la faillite
écoutez si vous faites sur lui personne
tu vas voir financer un employeur sur le
bord de la faillite les banques menacent
de ne plus prêter aux entreprises en
difficulté si elles ne sont pas
remboursés en premier en cas de faillite
mais les deux experts pensent que pour
s'assurer d'être payés les banques vont
plutôt exigé des compagnies que leur
fonds de retraite n'est pas de déficit
l'employeur yare pression sur lui pour
qu'il le kong au lieu de distribuer des
dividendes aux actionnaires
on aimerait mieux de se mettre l'argent
dans ton régime de retraite et nous
avons réduit notre issement votre plus
prête à te prêter ou à refinancer
monsieur le premier ministre je vous le
demande
allez-vous examiner ce problème et vous
engager à changer les lois sur la
faillite et l'insolvabilité pour
protéger les retraités oui ou non n'est
pour l'instant le projet de loi de ce
que vidal n'a toujours pas été adopté
quatre jours le premier ministre refuse
de s'avancer fermement en faveur de
changements législatifs
il fera face à la même opposition depuis
100 d'ubi de l'est se déliter il faut
s'attendre à une levée massive de
boucliers ça va prendre beaucoup de
colonnes au parti libéral du canada pour
résister à cette pression d'eau
en attendant plusieurs retraités de
stelco n'ont toujours pas de certitude
que leur fonds de retraite sera
entièrement préservés pour aider à
combler le déficit stelco s'est engagé à
vendre des centaines d'hectares de
terrains industriels des terrains
contaminés
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'il faudrait un
jour compter sur des déchets pour
financer notre fonds de retraite
on a travaillé fort pour protéger notre
avenir ça devrait pas reposer uniquement
sur l'espoir
les retraités de services pour les mêmes
craintes pour leur avenir
un sentiment d'injustice le sentiment
d'avoir été trahis
6 at elle trahi ses travailleurs son
dernier président reste prudent j'ai une
excellente maîtrise du monde des
affaires
je comprends fort bien leurs arguments
yukiko mais brandon refuse de critiquer
les décisions prises avant son arrivée à
munich où il décroche j'ai fait tout mon
possible pour sauver la conquête et
s'était exceptionnellement difficile je
suis déçu de ne pas avoir atteint de
meilleurs résultats
voilà ce que je dirais le principal
actionnaire et d'hellemmes peux tu nous
as écrit qu'il a toujours cru dans la
survie de la compagnie mais qu'il n'est
pas responsable des décisions prises au
canada et qu'il a directement bénéficié
d'une partie seulement des dividendes
alors est ce que monsieur laporte est un
machin est un homme de finale ou autre
chose
la cour supérieure de l'ontario a
autorisé la tenue d'une enquête sur le
bien fondé d'une partie des milliards de
dividendes donner aux actionnaires alors
que la compagnie était en difficulté
l'issue de cette enquête ouvrira la
porte à de possibles poursuites civiles
contre la compagnie
les retraités de sérieuses n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot